please first allow me to take a moment
to say this next line perfectly thank
you to the Academy for this incredible
honor it really feels like a dream come
true moment and thank you to Shawn actor
the nice and amazing team for this
incredible week and before I introduce
my team just a few things that I want to
mention growing up in China and coming
to the u.s. when I was 15 and spending
the past ten years working hard trying
to pursue my filmmaking dream I always
found me trying to prove myself to one
person and that is my father
[Applause]
and I always it was always my dream to
see him you know maybe impressed by the
work that I do or like one day maybe say
to me you know son I'm proud of you
those kind of things in this past summer
I was home i sat down with him and then
the two of us I decided to show him the
chef during the entire time I was super
nervous and then afterwards he just sat
there quietly and then drink from his
teacup and man that was the longest sip
of tea I've ever experienced in my life
and and then he pat on my shoulder and
then he said to me it's not bad and I
know it's very far away from you know
saying I'm proud of you but you know if
you know him
this is the best line or the closest
line to show his love to me so so to him
and to my family in China thank you so
much for supporting me supporting my
strange dream in filmmaking Papa mama
cinema usually a lot o ordered richer
and now let me introduce my team and
this is my producer writer ethica and
thank you so much for bringing is such a
compelling original story to me and
trusting in me and then my production
designer Boni Mamba my writer Congo
Chiba NASA and our amazing cast Allen
roll
and our lead actor team love our editor
long way to and our cast
Raymond MA and our composure to cheer on
[Applause]
and also to those who are not here with
us today I was in fog refer carlo
mendoza our actor queen van Haney tab
Makar know Jamie Jon production manager
Don Hmong you'd have sound design eFilm
torpedo pictures and many other cast and
crew who helped on the film they're my
they're my collaborators my friends my
mentors and I can wait to make more
films with them also to the sloan
Foundation and our sponsors share among
curtain loggia and all our friends and
families who donated to us thank you so
much for the generous support without
you guys this film would never happen
and in of course to my school AFI I
couldn't be more proud to be among so
many talented filmmakers at the school
and thank you to my classmates
especially lo Cindy Andrew Shue and my
professors Peter Martin Andrew Wagner
Rob's para Barry Sabbath Patty West
Vanessa Haines Steven Leight Hill Neil
Kenton hey deal Abbott in Thomas Mahoney
also to 1fi alarm Julian Higgins who was
also a student having a word winner in
2011 thank you for being my friend my
mentor in my role model apologize if I
didn't get to mention everyone but to
all of those who supported us along the
way
were truly truly grateful and last but
not least back to the Academy thank you
again for recognizing our short film in
recognizing a story about
rebuilding human connections despite our
differences and as in Asian director
just want to thank the pioneers in our
community director and Lee I have to put
his name with me
hero Castle corrida bon giorno and many
many others who have paved the road for
us and I can't wait to join the
community and share more stories of our
community together thank you so much
[Applause]